On a peut-être un nouvel allié de prestige !
Si cette personne accepte de devenir notre conseiller...
On peut atteindre le trône de fer.
Mais qui est cette personne ?
Les mystères sont de...
- Apparemment, c'est le fils maudit de la maison des lions.
Tout le monde le cherche à la capitale.
Pour le buter, hein.
Pas pour lui donner des gâteaux.
C'est Yorel qui l'aurait reconnu dans une taverne.
Yorel il ramène plein de trucs des tavernes hein.
De la bouffe...
Des maladies...
Des...
Voici Lord Peter.
Faux nom.
Qui aurait perdu son argent aux jeux.
Histoire simple, efficace.
J'adhère !
Non mais tout est vrai hein.
C'est excellent, hein.
On vous a reconnu.
Faut lire entre les lignes.
Les mystères sont de...
Je l'ai reconnu.
Je suis hyper physionomiste.
Bon, je suis pas le mec auquel ils pensent.
Je leur ai dit.
Mais ils m'ont donné ça.
En échange de conseils pour avoir le trône.
Alors...
Bah je suis resté.
On est nuls en complot.
Une fois j'ai essayé d'en échafauder un, c'était la cata.
Fallait tuer le roi déguisé en prostituée.
Ou, tuer une prostituée déguisé en roi.
Ou, tuer le roi déguisé en gigot.
On a besoin de Peter.
Faut toujours être là où on vous attend pas.
Voyez moi par exemple, ma spécialité c'est le combat à mains nues.
75 combats, 76 K.O.
Vous vous avez mis un mec K.O. 2 fois dans le même combat ?
Bon, pour commencer...
Faudrait penser à changer votre emblème.
Il est pas assez... bien.
Passe-moi le vin.
Ouais mais ça vous avez raison parce que l'emblème c'est vraiment important.
Parce que, par exemple, le lion c'est royal.
Le cerf c'est majestueux.
Et le dragon c'est flippant.
C'est juste flippant.
Et si on mettait une belette ?
Ou une chatte ?
Un drapeau avec une chatte dessus ?
Je dis n'importe quoi.
Freestyle.
Et ils m'adorent.
Tout le monde l'aime bien, mais moi j'ai plus envie de le vendre.
Pour moi, ce que je vois, c'est 1m20 de traître à la couronne.
Je vais envoyer un corbeau à la capitale.
On a reçu 2 messages indiquant la même personne à 2 endroits différents.
Donc je suis venu vérifier.
Non, c'est pas lui.
Vous aurez pas l'argent.
Voilà, c'était une mission assez courte.
Wow, wow, quel argent ?
Il dit n'importe quoi !
T'as essayé de me vendre ?
On va pas se battre, hein ?
Je suis le maître d'arme...
Papa ?
Il l'a double KO-té !
Et c'était pas du tout lui.
Je suis certain qu'on peut atteindre le trône de fer.
Faut juste trouver la petite astuce qui nous permettrait de survoler le pouvoir des 7 familles...
Qui sont prêtes à tout pour atteindre le trône de fer avant nous.
Faut penser malin.